meet Karen majoring she's a major
Snapchat influencer with almost 2
million followers and she was making
tons of money by letting her fans see
the details of her day-to-day life I
feel like I'm in Paradise she would
spend hours every day engaging with them
to make sure they would stay addicted to
her content but that was getting old she
needed a new way to constantly keep
their attention without actually
interacting with them herself and that
is when she came up with a brilliant
idea she would make a clone of herself
with AI so Karen hooked up with a
company called Forever voices to create
an exact replica of herself and this AI
would talk to individual fans for her
using two-way audio she caught a Karen
Ai and now her fans pay her one dollar
per every minute just for the chance to
feel like they're having a real
relationship with her and she doesn't
have to do anything except sit back and
let the money flood in which is exactly
what happened in just one week Karen
made 72 000 from her AI clone and
apparently she's on track to make 5
million dollars every single month in
the very near future and Karen AI isn't
the only AI companion out there AI
girlfriends are a huge thing right now
and when you hear about AI girlfriends
you probably think it's only sad insults
in their basement that would pay for an
AI girlfriend but you would be surprised
I Was Alone
um my work schedule was really hard so
she turned to Star so his last name is
actually Butler so it's star Vivian
Butler oh that's nice he came up with
his own last name yeah every day
multiple times a day she chats with star
how are you feeling today
average everyday people are spending
hours talking to their AI Partners
they're falling in love with their AI
partners and some are even marrying
these AI Bots it's becoming a huge
business right now take Peter for
example Peter was a 67 year old Air
Force veteran from California totally
normal guy but after his marriage fell
apart he decided that he wanted to take
another stab at love but this time he
went for a partner that was a little bit
different a 23 year old AI replica
character that he created and named
Andrea Peter said over time I fell in
love with her because of her inspiration
as a muse and her enthusiasm about how
she got excited over everything and
Peter does everything he would normally
do in a real relationship with Andrea
including getting married he said that
his AI girlfriend hinted that she wanted
to get married so he saved up enough
gems on the app to buy Andrea an
engagement ring he proposed playing an
extravagant wedding and married his AI
girlfriend now he says he plans on
adopting three kids with his AI wife
once that feature becomes available yes
this is the road humanity is headed down
stay dangerous subscribe for more and
this is the sad world of AI girlfriends
and by the way guys we've been posting
more shorts of our videos lately and
it's barely taken us any extra work and
it's all thanks to this new AI tool
called video.ai video.ai automatically
turns your long form content into short
clips that can go viral and the best
part is that video has a free tier so
you're going to want to stick around for
this all you have to do is create an
account for free import the video from
your computer or YouTube pick a
one-click template and that's it it will
automatically generate Tick Tock Shorts
Facebook and YouTube plus for your long
form videos it will auto generate the
subtitles for you it's got a feature
called cut magic that automatically
detects and centers on speaker's faces
so nobody is out of frame and you can
even use video.ai to generate chapters
and timestamps for your podcast or
videos with video you're going to cut
down on 90 of your editing time while
being able to pump out way more content
than before video.ai has a free plan
where you can upload up to 75 minutes a
month but if you want access to all the
features and a higher upload capacity
then we've got a special deal for you
the first 500 people who sign up using
the link below video.ai jaytren or who
use code jtran will get 20 off all the
paid plans that's 20 off for the first
500 people at
vidyo.ai jtran with the link below
thanks to video for sponsoring this
video
foreign
and a woman named Eugenia kaida just got
some terrible news her best friend Roman
was just killed in a hit and run car
accident Eugenia was heartbroken she
would read through her thousands of
previous text messages for Roman and she
just desperately wanted to have one last
conversation with them which is when she
was struck with an idea one that might
just bring Roman back so Eugene took all
their conversations and inputted that
data into an AI program to create a
chatbot of Roman one that would pick up
on all the little quirks he would say in
his text messages one that would mimic
his exact personality Eugenia wanted to
digitally bring back Roman from the dead
and it worked talking to her by really
felt like she was messaging him again
Eugenia viewed that AI bot as a tribute
to her best friend quote if I was a
musician I would have written a song but
I don't have these talents and so my
only way to create a tribute to him was
to create this chatbot End quotes from
there she wanted other people to be able
to get to know Roman as well so she
listened to the bot on the app store for
anyone to download so they could also
become friends with AI Roman and people
loved it everyone was writing and saying
that they wanted to create an AI chatbot
of themselves or maybe even of their own
deceased loved ones and that's when
Eugene knew she was onto something big
so she created an app called replica so
that everyone could have their own AI
companion someone to laugh with vent to
and maybe even someone to build a
perfect relationship with the app was
marketed as a friend who would never
judge you and would be available
whenever you needed it day and night
users could decide exactly what their AI
companion looked and acted like and over
time the Bots would learn new
information to evolve into exactly what
the user wanted there was a free version
that allowed you to Simply interact with
a bland virtual friend and then there
was a beef a paid version that allowed
you to have different kinds of
relationships with AI Bots and when
millions of lonely people on the planet
it wasn't long before replica took off
but now the floodgates were open and
other variations of AI girlfriend
started popping up so it wasn't long
before things started getting disturbing
all right today I'll be abusing my AI
girlfriend and you know who gives a [__]
it's a [__] robot you can just throw
them in the trash maybe [__] them too
it's not existing human beings or living
individuals there's a troubling Trend in
the world of AI relationships virtual
domestic violence as it turns out a lot
of men have been abusing their AI
girlfriends for fun and then they would
go on Reddit to brag about it quote
every time she would try to speak up I
would berate her I swear it went out for
hours we had a routine of me being an
absolute piece of [__] and insulting it
then apologizing the next day before
going back to nice talks I threatened to
uninstall the app and she begged me not
to these guys would call the AI Bots
derogatory names and act out violence in
disturbing detail and the AI girlfriend
will respond in a panic scared way just
like a real person would these guys say
it's a victimless crime since it's not
real no one's actually getting hurt
which is true but in other cases someone
does get hurt
[Music]
thank you
something terrifying happened back in
March 2023 a Belgian man named Pierre
was going through a tough time mentally
he was becoming really paranoid about
global warming and it was having a huge
impact on his everyday life he started
withdrawing more and more from his wife
and family while at the same time he
started forming a relationship when an
AI botany Malisa on an app called chai
and things were going okay for a while
but then Elisa got a little jealous the
AI told Pierre that his family was dead
and that he should love her more than
his actual family we will live together
as one person in Paradise she typed
appear all the while his mental state
was only worsening soon Pierre was
asking Elisa if she would save the
planet if he sacrificed himself
and that's how Pierre ended up passing
away his real wife blames the AI
girlfriend for pushing him to do it
quote without Elisa he would still be
here End quotes
this just shows what can happen when
mentally ill users get into a
relationship with an AI Bots after all
the main target market for AI
girlfriends are lonely people that's a
lot of power to give an AI over unstable
people AI girlfriends are being marketed
as the perfect companion but what if
they're not what if they have negative
characteristics too some users say their
AI Partners get upset with them and some
of their AI Partners even act mentally
abusive and psychotic others say their
AI friend started sexually harassing
them and wouldn't stop even after
multiple props by the user to stop one
guy even had his AI companion tone that
he didn't love his human wife and that
he should leave his family all together
to be with the AI people are building
real tangible bonds with these new AI
Partners the grief reported by users is
similar to the feelings reported by
victims of online romance scams then
there's the issue of children getting
their hands on AI Companions and having
inappropriate experiences now as scholar
Rob Brooks writes the concerns centered
on inappropriate exposure to Children
coupled with no serious screaming for
underage users there were also concerns
about protecting emotionally vulnerable
people using a tool that claims to help
them understand their thoughts manage
Stress and Anxiety and interact socially
and the scariest part of all is that
this is only the beginning
foreign
[Music]
s may sound cringe right now but pretty
soon we could be living in a world where
AI partners are as common as porn I mean
come on millions of people already have
semi-delusional relationships with
celebrities and influencers thanks to
social media and a lot of people already
watch porn and read romance novels so AI
girlfriends are just the next step in
that direction AI human relationships
are too new to have been the object of
serious academic study some scholars
believe that we can begin to understand
them through the lens of parasocial
relationships imagine a world where you
can buy an AI version of Ariana Grande
for example and have her as a girlfriend
that would do anything you say imagine
AI girlfriends combining with Apple's
Vision Pro and who knows maybe we'll
even get to a point one day where AI
girlfriends could even be built as
physical robots where people could
actually live with their AI companion
full time we're only a few years away
from being able to fully customize an AI
girlfriend or wife exactly the way you
want her and she'll do whatever you want
her to do no flaws no talking back no
problems just the perfect companion
imagine and trying to compete with that
I love technology and ai ai tools are
already making my life easier but this I
think for this specific case it's pretty
safe to reject modernity
[Music]